PENG YING: Hi, My
name is Peng Ying
and I work on the
Google Wallet team.
I'm here to talk about
the Instant Buy API.
Instant Buy is a product that
enables seamless purchases
of physical goods and
services from mobile devices.
For purchases in
Android apps, Google
provides two payment APIs.
For digital goods, you can
use the In-app Billing API.
For physical goods
and services, you
can use the Instant Buy API
to enable seamless purchases
for your users.
And seamless purchases
of physical goods
are important because
we're starting
to see more apps
interacting with the world
and creating better experiences.
For example, rideshare
companies are
transforming the
transportation industry.
Before you would stay on the
corner and hope an empty cab
would pass you by, but now you
know exactly where that car is
and when it will arrive.
And there's no more dealing
with broken credit card readers,
there's no more
figuring out tip,
there's no more manual
payment whatsoever.
Everything is handled by
the device in your pocket.
And when you get to
your destination,
you just get out
of the car and go.
The way that we order
food is changing.
More restaurants like Domino's
have mobile ordering apps.
Aggregators like Eat24 are
enabling smaller restaurants
to accept mobile orders.
I never know when that next
craving is going to strike,
but when it does,
I'm fully prepared.
Travel is becoming
more efficient.
Companies like HotelTonight,
AirBnB, and Expedia
are enabling travelers
to book on the go.
And by enabling last minute
purchasing and filling
mobile consumer
needs, they can help
reduce the vacancy
rates of businesses.
Lastly, we're starting to
see this internet of things
taking shape.
New experiences
powered by the web.
Smart parking meters.
Why do you need to go back
to the meter to add time
or to figure out how
much time is left?
Well, you don't.
You can do that from your phone.
And these meter apps
should do other things too,
like tell you where
you parked and how
to walk back to your car.
And when mobile devices
integrate with cars,
you should see even
more interaction.
Imagine seeing all of the open
parking spots on your car's
navigation screen,
wouldn't that be awesome?
With Zipcar, City
CarShare, or iDrive
you can find and reserve a
car rental from your phone.
Whenever you need a car,
you can find one around you
and book it.
These services provide an
amazing amount of freedom.
Developers like you are
thinking up of and building
the apps that change
the way that we
interact with the world.
All powered by the
smart, contextual devices
in our pockets.
And Instant Buy makes payments
for these things seamless.
If you're developing an app
that sells physical goods
or services, you need to
integrate Instant Buy.
Also, like many
things Google, it's
free, so why wouldn't
you integrate?
You only need to pay for
your payment processor.
So how does it
simplify purchasing?
Well, as many users know, check
out on the phone is a pain.
And as many developers
know, this pain
can cause a huge
conversion drop-off.
Here's one example, I have
to type in my name, my street
address, my zip, my city, my
state, and my phone number just
to start.
Then I get to open
my wallet, I have
to get out my credit card,
type in the 16 digits,
CVV, expiration, and if I have
a separate billing address,
I pretty much just give up
and go buy it on Amazon.
Every additional field requested
is an opportunity for me
to hit the Home button and do
something else like play Candy
Crush.
And for every app that
I want to purchase from,
and need to go
through this tedious
process over and
over and over again.
To improve this user experience
and create a seamless purchase
flow, Instant Buy
uses Google Wallet.
Wallet stores the user's
payment credentials in the Cloud
and makes them
accessible to developers.
This means that any one who's
purchased an item on a Google
property such as Play,
YouTube, Drive, or Music,
or purchasing an app that's
integrated within that
billing-- such as Clash
of Clans, Candy Crush,
or Pandora-- or purchase an app
that's integrated with Instant
Buy-- such as Uber, Eat24,
Domino's-- already have
their credentials stored
with Google Wallet.
That's a lot of users.
So instead of type, type,
type, type, type, type,
type, with Instant
Buy users can just
click, click, click, and buy.
Google generates a
one-time use credit card
that's backed by the customer's
stored payment credentials.
This one-time card and the
customer's billing information
is then passed to your app and
you can feed the credit card
number into your
existing purchase flow
and process the order just
like a regular credit card
transaction.
What this means is that
consumers experience
a seamless purchase with
credentials secured by Google
and merchants can
add Instant Buy
without changing any existing
payment processing code.
And did I mention it's free?
So I'm assuming that you want
to learn more about integration,
so let's walk through some
of the high level steps
to integrate Instant
Buy on Android.
First you need to
get credentials.
For testing purposes, you can
use a Google Wallet sandbox
account.
For a production
account, you need
to sign up at
getinstantbuy.withgoogle.com.
The Instant Buy flow consists
of three main steps in addition
to charging your order-- Masked
Wallet, Full Wallet, and Notify
Transaction status.
You handle charging the order
just as you normally would.
Now, let's see what this looks
like in a real purchase flow.
Here is your typical
shopping cart page.
Selecting Buy with Google will
initiate the Masked Wallet
request.
The Masked Wallet
flow allows the user
to choose their payment and
shipping information populated
from Google Wallet.
Once a user selects
their information,
Instant Buy returns an
obfuscated version of it
to your app.
This obfuscated information
includes the last four
of the user's credit card
and their billing zip.
You should then use
this information
to calculate shipping,
if necessary,
and display their information
on the payment confirmation
page for user verification.
Once a customer's ready, they'll
tap to complete the order.
Your confirmed order button
calls a Full Wallet request
which will return the
credit card details.
You can then charge a card
using your normal payment flow
and show the user
your receipt page
and send the transaction
status notification
that the transaction
went through smoothly.
Now let's take a look
at the code behind this.
First, we create our
Mass Wallet request.
This defines your
information that we're
asking from a customer and the
estimated order information.
In this specific case, we're
asking for the user's phone
number, the shipping
address, but you
should minimize the
request for your needs.
You don't want to be asking
for the shipping address
if you don't need it.
Then we create and instantiate
the Wallet fragment style
and options.
Here it's a Buy
with Google button
that's pointed towards sandbox
and uses the Holo Light theme.
Finally, we initialize
a Wallet fragment.
You need to use a
fragment manager
to replace a holder layout
section with the Wallet
fragment.
This will create an add the Buy
with Google button to your app.
You also need to handle
the onActivityResult
to get the Mass
Wallet response which
contains the obfuscated
user information.
Once you have the
Mass Wallet response,
you can create a Full
Wallet request object
and issue the Full
Wallet request
to retrieve customer
payment credentials.
You can then charge
the credentials,
and after charging,
notify Google
of the transaction status.
And that's it.
It's that easy.
So if you're working
on an app where
users can purchase
physical goods or services,
you need to integrate
Instant Buy.
Integration is quick, the
user experience is seamless,
and it's free.
While we've only showed
Android in this video,
Instant Buy also supports
the web, mobile web, and iOS.
For detailed information
on integration
and a step-by-step
tutorial, take a look
at our developer documentation.
I can't wait to
see what you build.
I'm Peng Ying and
thanks for watching.